- [Narrator] Middle Ground
is a social experiment,
that brings humans with
opposing beliefs together.
These discussions may contain viewpoints
that are the result of misinformation.
Remember to seek out experts,
and to be critical of your own biases
while forming an opinion.
Please see the humanity
in each participant,
and as always, we encourage empathy.
- You're equating some
minor inconveniences
in your privileged life to-
- Why would you assume my life
is privileged?
- An unsupported-
- But why would you see my
life as privileged though?
I mean, I don't say that about you.
Why would you see my life as privileged?
- I'm privileged.
- Okay, that's fine,
but why would you see
my life as privileged?
- For one, you're a man.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- [Narrator] Step forward if
you agree with the prompt.
The government has no right
to tell people what to do with their body.
(footsteps approaching)
- Vaccines.
- Yes.
Yeah, I don't think the
government has the right
to tell you what you-
- I'm gonna step out, sorry.
- Okay. I stood here because of vaccines,
but I know a lot of you guys
probably looking at me like,
"Oh, what about abortion?"
Now thing is, when it comes to abortion,
two bodies are involved.
It's the woman, and it's the fetus.
The fetus, has a heartbeat, it has DNA.
It should have rights.
- When?
- Life begins at conception.
- That's not when the
heart's there though.
- Heart beat starts at four weeks.
It's not just a clump
of cells, it is life.
At 21 weeks, it can live
outside of the womb.
Abortion ends with murder and death.
- Over 90% of abortions happen
within the first 10 weeks.
- That still, I think
that's not acceptable.
- But they still have the
potential of having life though.
The mortality rate of a fetus
getting aborted is 100%.
It's gonna die when it's aborted.
- And you're very lucky you'll
never have to experience,
what it's like to have
to make that choice.
- But what if I become a father,
and the woman who I got pregnant
wants to have an abortion,
it's gonna affect me.
- You would have a discussion
with your partner then,
and decide what you are gonna do
and be glad that you have a choice,
- Of course.
- to even discuss
with that partner.
- Unfortunately, human nature.
If you take away the option
or the right to do that,
then they'll find it another way.
- And it will be unsafe.
- And would you support the mom?
Would you support the
mom in that scenario?
- If the mom had an abortion or the mom-
- No, no, no, if she gave birth.
- Oh, of course.
I would support her, I'd say,
"What you do is a good thing and-"
- No, no, no, support her financially
for the rest of her life,
or for the rest of the baby's life.
- Are you talking about like,
what do you mean me support
her, like as a citizen or?
- If somebody has a baby.
- We do have child support,
and it comes from taxpayer money.
- There's foster care, there's adoption,
there's mothers waiting.
- Those systems are very broken,
and people all the time
are trying to stop funding
for programs like that.
- Now, I want to ask you guys,
do you support vaccine mandates?
- Yes.
- You stepped forward
and said the government
shouldn't tell you what
do with your body though.
Why would you support-
- My issue is, is that I
believe that the government
should not be able to tell
me what to do with my body,
but I have to accept the consequences,
for the choices that I make with my body.
The vaccines for instance,
I absolutely felt that
everyone should get vaccinated.
Why?
Because this was a pandemic.
But if you don't want to,
I don't think the government
should have to tell you
that you have to,
but you then have to
suffer the consequences
of your choices.
Which means you cannot
patronize certain places.
You can't put other people at risk.
- I know you're saying they're
doing it to protect us.
The coronavirus has a
survival rate almost 98%, 99%,
and we're mandating these vaccines.
Why are we not mandating the flu?
- What's frightening to me is that,
you're equating some minor inconveniences
in your privileged life to-
- Why would you assume my life
is privileged?
- An unsupported-
- But why would you say my
life is privileged though?
You don't know my life.
I don't say that about you,
why would you say my life is privileged?
- I'm privileged.
- Okay, that's fine,
but why would you assume
my life is privileged?
- For one, you're a man.
- You know, most people
commit suicide, are men.
Most people who work in
dangerous workplaces are men.
Most people who fight in war are men.
- And who set that system up?
- Men.
- [Narrator] I'm gonna ask the
disagreers to step forward.
- Well, I think I give a
unique perspective on this,
'cause I actually do agree
with the vaccine mandate.
I think COVID was just a huge disaster,
and I think it could
have ended a lot sooner,
if things were more organized.
- Definitely as far as
whether the government
should intervene on people's bodies,
I think there are a lot of instances
where the government should.
One to protect the society in general,
especially in cases, such as a pandemic,
where the disease could
literally wipe out cities.
In other instances as
well, such as drug use,
I think the government should intervene.
Because when you have a
society that's addicted
to opioids or crack, it
spreads like wildfire
and I've seen it firsthand,
and it's very difficult to control
without the help of government.
Now on the topic of abortion,
that one's very complex,
and in general I always want to favor
a woman's right to choose.
But I think there's also a
very fundamental question
that both of you brought up,
is at what point is a
fetus, a human or a person?
Let's say a child is
eight months in the womb,
and at that point, the baby has a heart,
the baby has a brain, has legs, has arms,
do you think it's okay
for that to be terminated?
- Nobody is doing that.
And nobody is having
abortions with viable fetuses,
unless it is a medical emergency
that will kill the baby,
and the mother.
- My name is Ben.
I'm a business consultant
for a telecom company,
and I'm a liberal dad.
When it comes to the abortion issue,
I am not exactly sure where I stand.
I am not pro-choice or pro-life.
- My name is Dawn.
I'm a regional sales manager
for a dialysis company,
as well as a therapist,
and I'm a liberal parent.
As far as my views on abortion,
to be honest, it just makes me very sad.
I can't believe that we
are moving backwards,
by taking people's rights away
to choose what's happening to their body.
- [Narrator] Not being an LGBTQ+ ally
makes someone a bad person.
- It's strong, it's a little strong.
- It's a general way to put it.
I would question someone's empathy.
- That's it.
And their awareness
of the other people around them,
because I guarantee, you know someone-
- Absolutely and their environment.
- Right.
Discussing the validity of the existence
of other human beings, isn't a
political issue, that's like-
- It's there.
- There's something wrong
with you if you are like, "No
trans people don't exist."
Obviously they do.
I would like to think
that it's a safer world,
- Yes.
- to be LGBTQ,
but that would be naive.
- Of course.
- People are getting
murdered for being trans.
- Yes.
- And gay.
It's scary.
I have three kids.
I have three boys.
- Oh.
- One of them is trans.
I worry that.
I mean, for however progressive
a new generation seems,
that I have to think about,
will there be violence done?
Which I mean, every parent
worries about violence.
That's part of the gig
of being a parent.
- Yes.
- And I've got an extra,
I've got a new layer.
(Cindy laughs)
My child is in a wonderfully
privileged situation
- Okay.
where they have
a lot of support.
- Okay, okay, that helps.
- But as they get older,
their circle gets wider,
and my sphere of influence
gets less effective
as they get older, you know?
Hi, I'm Cindy.
I am a stay-at-home mom,
and I am a liberal parent.
One of my children came
out as trans two years ago.
Mine and my husband's
response was, "That's great.
Would you like to go by these pronouns,
and would you like to pick out a name?
Let's make sure that we
talk to a gender specialist
so we know what options there are,
and we'll just take
this one step at a time.
We'll move forward with the
best information possible."
- [Narrator] Can the
disagreers a step forward?
- I can provide a unique
perspective on this
'cause I'm actually bisexual.
So I think not being an ally,
as long as you're not harming people,
you're not harassing people,
you're not posting on social
media that these people suck,
then I don't think you're
a bad person for that.
- As a Christian, I don't
think that being LGBTQ aligns
with God's view of the family.
Doesn't mean that I will disrespect them
in any way, I just think that it's a sin.
- As far as your faith is concerned,
what would happen if your
child came out to you
that they were gay, bisexual, trans.
- I think that if the sin
is not practiced upon,
it's not a problem, it can be dealt with.
Especially with transitioning,
it usually comes from mental
problems like depression,
anxiety, and all those things.
- So you think they can be
kind of taught to not be gay?
- No.
- Pray the gay away.
- Do you support conversion therapy?
- No, I don't think that
we can convert anyone
into doing anything.
I would not ostracize my child,
but I would not support it.
Just like I don't support any sin.
- So I think that if you
want to be transgender,
you could be transgender.
We live in a, again, I said a free nation.
But if you're asking for my opinion,
I believe that men and women
are completely different.
We have different chromosomes,
different bone structure.
If you are a transgender woman,
I still view you as a man.
You could express yourself
as a woman, that's fine.
But I don't believe that
society should automatically,
say that, "Okay, you are a woman."
Let's say for instance,
there's a 18 year old biological man,
but says that there are a woman now,
they still have male genitalia.
They could walk into
a woman's locker room,
and show off their male genitalia,
I don't agree with that,
I don't think that's okay.
- That's not happening.
- That is happening though.
- Is it really happening?
- That is literally transphobia.
(group chattering)
- Not even a trans person, it
could just be a creepy guy,
like pretending to be-
- Yes, yes creepy guys.
I'm much more danger in a women's restroom
from a Cis gender straight creepy guy,
than I am trans person.
- That gives them the excuse,
that's what I'm trying to say.
- So do you support
gender neutral bathrooms,
- Yes.
like women and men can go
into the same bathroom.
Do you think that could increase
the chances of rape or assault?
- They already exist?
It's interesting that men are
only concerned about this rape
in the bathroom,
when we're having a
conversation about trans folk.
- But gender neutral bathrooms
just stem from this idea though.
- No, this idea that
rape is gonna suddenly go
on the rise because of
gender neutral bathrooms,
stems from transphobia.
- I'm Eden, I'm 16 years old,
and I'm on the conservative teen side.
I think that transitioning
does more harm than good,
and I think that we are born
in the body that we're given,
and we should stay that way.
God has created us in his image
and I don't think we should
change the way we are.
- [Narrator] Owning a gun
is a basic human right.
- I absolutely hate hearing
about school shootings
on the news, and just shootings
in general, it's horrible.
This isn't like, Spider-Man's
not gonna save people,
people have the right
to protect themselves.
- A lot of mass shooters
target gun-free zones
because they know there's
not gonna be a person
who's going to fight against
them, or shoot them back.
There's a lot of mass
shootings at schools,
and that's because schools
have gun free zones.
I view owning a gun as a
right to defend myself.
You look at countries that
have banned guns in the past,
the USSR, Nazi Germany.
You look at China under Mao Zedong,
they strip their citizens of arms
so they could oppress them.
And I think the reason
why our founding fathers
enshrined the second amendment,
is because they wanted
us to protect ourselves
against tyrannical government,
and to protect ourselves
against danger around us too.
- I think that, from
a woman's perspective,
if, as a woman, you get
into a dangerous situation,
for example, with a man, having a gun
and knowing how to use a gun,
is the only way that will protect me.
Having my tiny little pepper
spray won't help me forever.
I think definitely if you take away guns,
the bad guys will always get
their guns one way or another.
- I live in Los Angeles, and
LA has strict gun control laws.
This is my perspective of it.
I think LA has become
a more dangerous city,
and I feel very unsafe
walking down the street,
just not armed.
Crime is on the rise in America,
and I think one of the ways to stop crime
is by owning a gun.
- I definitely think that
there should be this control
in place to who buys guns.
You couldn't just be able to
go to a store and buy a gun,
there should be regulations
into who buys guns,
and who shoots a gun.
- I actually debated whether
or not I was gonna sit down,
because I do believe people
have the right to bear arms.
I do.
My issue is what kind
of arms they're bearing.
I believe people should get to go hunt,
but do you need a
semi-automatic rifle to do that?
I'll tell you personally,
I'm afraid of guns,
personally myself.
But I just think there need
to be stricter regulations
with it.
- But the majority of
people who die by gunshot,
are women in a domestic
violence situation.
So mass shootings definitely,
don't want automatic rifles,
against that, nobody needs 'em.
But the most dangerous gun,
is the one in your home.
- I do wanna ask you a question.
Do you think that women should
have the right to bear arms
to protect themselves?
- Yes, yeah.
I'm not against the right to own guns.
The prompt was, do you think
owning a gun is a human right?
And I don't agree with that.
- In my perspective,
I grew up in a gun riddled neighborhood.
I myself am a gun owner now,
because of the fact that I had to create
some type of means of self-defense.
So why did you disagree?
I disagree because I
would prefer not to be,
I think it's not a human right,
as much as almost a necessity
for a lot of people.
And not everyone,
there's a lot of neighborhoods
that are very safe,
but even in a safe
neighborhood, you can be robbed,
you can be killed.
I've been stuck up several
times with a gun to my face,
and all I could think
of is, "Man, if I die,
it's gonna be because
I didn't have a weapon
to help protect me."
- Do you think that we
should take away all guns
from the entire world?
- Yes, if there was like a
magnet, like magneto from "X-Men"
and he just suck up all the guns,
I think that would be such a better place.
- [Narrator] My political opinions,
have hurt my relationships
with friends and family.
- During 2020, when
America got really like
politically intense, and my teacher,
she was very politically active,
and she wanted us to speak our voices,
and they found out I was conservative
and they said, "Okay, you're
completely going against
what we believe."
Like the whole school's very liberal,
and I guess they just
kind of pushed me away.
- Did you feel like you
would get bullied after?
- No. I'll just get looks.
Some people come up and
say, "You're racist,
or you're xenophobic."
They would tell me, "Oh,
do you support Trump?"
But I just brushed it off.
I told them, "Hey, I respect
that you think like this,
please respect me."
- I think that that is,
whether or not we have the same ideas,
I think that that is still
an admirable quality.
- Yeah.
- Despite getting looks,
or feeling like maybe you don't belong,
that you're still...
You have your convictions.
- Yeah.
- So I can respect that you're convicted.
(Cindy laughs)
- I think being liberal,
we think of the right as
being stuck in the sand.
It's interesting to hear that liberals
were not having his right opinion.
I think that everyone
should have their opinion.
- Well, I think we're talking about issues
that aren't a matter of opinion,
but a matter of your morality,
the value of human lives.
I've had to personally block
a few people on Facebook,
family members.
- Oh wow.
- Mostly men that are married to the women
in my family.
Like, "Hey, this conversation
is really getting personal
and hurtful, and if you carry on this way,
I'm gonna have to block you."
- Were they harassing you?
- I feel very harassed
yeah, and belittled.
- Were you ostracized? Or
was there someone that you-
- I think on my end, it was myself.
I understand people have different beliefs
and I respect that,
and I think it's good for
everyone to share their beliefs.
That's the way we progress.
But I think when people become ignorant,
or offensive consistently,
without any type of evidence,
or any type of backup behind that,
that's the point where I say,
"You know what? I probably
shouldn't be friends with you,
because you may smile in my face,
but behind my back, you
have a different sentiment."
- I haven't lost any
relationships, because me
and my friends don't
really dive into politics.
We kind of just play video games,
and talk about comics together.
I think if you lose a
relationship over politics,
that's kind of sad.
- Unfortunately, it's
a part of growing up.
- Yeah. For sure.
- Hopefully you won't lose any friends,
but usually as you get older,
start to see those
divides a little clearer.
- I mean, you guys are older than us,
was it like this, going
back, now 20 years ago?
- Politics has changed so much,
and I think you touched on it,
that now it's being associated,
policy is being associated with ethics.
I haven't lost any friendships
or relationships because I
won't allow that to happen.
I believe that the majority
of us, probably about 80%,
are in the middle with varying degrees.
And there are those people who
are very, very conservative,
very, very ultraliberal,
who are the outliers.
- Right, I think it's subtle.
Where you have somebody that you meet with
on a regular basis.
You talk with them, you have a good time.
If topics get brought up,
and it's a, "Oh, okay.
You're one of those."
They don't tell you that to your face,
but it's kind of subtle.
- And also I think with the
prevalence of social media,
people's opinions are
a lot more out there.
- I never understood why anyone
posted political opinions
on social media?
I think it's just annoying.
- Well I have three kids.
They know more about politics
than I did when I was voting age.
- It's annoying, yeah.
- I think it's very encouraging,
because they're gonna be more informed
when they are a voting age.
- I mean, yeah, it just
makes life more divisive.
There's more arguments and stuff.
And more, and more relationships ending
because politics is
such a big part of life.
- Hi, my name is Scott.
I am a liberal parent.
I have many children, I have four.
My oldest daughter is extremely left wing.
My two middle daughters are roughly right
in the middle there, and
then Chase is conservative.
- My name is Chase.
I'm 19 years old, and I'm on
the conservative teen side.
My dad, Scott, we talk about politics,
mostly gun rights, and the
government, and the economy.
We disagree, but we like
hearing each other's side.
- [Narrator] The feminist
movement is overrated.
- Oh yes.
- The reason I sat down,
is because feminism,
as we know it in social media,
and the marches, is
generally run by white women.
And we don't have a lot
of intersectionality.
Margaret Sanger.
- Margaret Sanger.
- Yeah, and-
- Susan B. Anthony.
- Susan B. Anthony,
total racist.
The women that headed up
the suffragette movement,
they were not inclusive.
- Of course, yes.
- And they wanted rights for white women.
- That's true.
- And that thread
has followed us, to be very
exclusionary to black women,
disabled women, women of
color, indigenous women.
- I don't think that feminism in America
is based off racism.
The reason why there's
more white feminists
is because there's a higher
white population in America.
So generally there's gonna
be more white feminists,
because of that.
- Hmm.
- I think that definitely in
the beginning of feminism,
feminists wanted votes for women.
That women would be allowed to work,
would be allowed to go to
universities, and such.
I definitely agree with that,
but I think that feminism has gone too far
into saying, "My body, my choice."
And saying that women
are not at all equal.
Saying that women are being
suppressed by white men
and such things.
- No.
We got a long way to go,
there's just not enough done.
- In America, or just
in the world in general.
- Well, America for sure.
The world in general is
a heck of a lot worse
than America.
- Yeah, I agree with you.
- I think that women should be able to do
everything that men can,
but we also have to protect ourselves.
So if you wanna be a stay-at-home mom,
and do one of the hardest
jobs on the planet,
you absolutely should be able to do that.
But you should also
discuss with your partner
and put in things into place,
so that you're protected
if you choose to do that.
Some women aren't doing that,
like life insurance and things like that.
I think part of feminism is being able
to take care of yourself.
- [Narrator] Capitalism
is failing our society.
- This system that just values
production, consumerism,
production, consumerism, until you die,
doesn't work for anybody,
but a very, very small
percentage of billionaires,
and it's all baloney
that the system is rigged
to keep workers working,
and the rich just keep getting richer.
- Yeah, I think there could
be some good in capitalism,
which is like the innovation part of it.
But in general, capitalism
definitely sucks from the poor.
There's a lot of industries
that definitely shouldn't
have any capitalism
involved at all.
The medical field.
It's unjust that certain
people get better care
than other people,
just because they're more
financially well off.
Who are they to determine
the value of life?
The healthcare system creates such profit,
and that profit is created
off the misery of others,
of the illness of others,
including the prison system,
where you have jails
that are privately owned.
Because at that point,
what you have is a hotel, and
you want to fill up the hotel.
Why would there be a business,
that profits off of crime,
that doesn't make any sense,
if you put profit ahead of people,
people are going to suffer, obviously.
- So you said, only the
billionaire succeed in capitalism,
and I gotta disagree with that,
because I'm the CEO of my own company.
A couple months ago, I
started a jewelry company,
and I'm not a billionaire,
but it's been relatively
successful enough,
I can like make rent, and go
through college a bit, so.
I think there's people like
me who own a small business,
who capitalism really benefits.
- If capitalism isn't the solution,
then what is the solution?
- Do you wanna hear it?
- Socialism?
- Socialism.
- Problem with democratic socialism,
I mean, you talk about how capitalism
hurts the middle class,
but in reality if democratic
socialism was tried,
the middle class are gonna
be paying way more taxes,
not just the rich.
You see the rich don't pay
taxes because they don't work.
They make money off assets.
The middle class, they work.
And because they're working,
they're gonna be paying more taxes,
under a proposal like Bernie Sanders,
or I don't know, AOC or Ilhan Omar.
- I personally am okay
with paying higher taxes.
I would love people who
make billions of dollars
to pay their fair share of taxes.
But increased taxes,
for a better situation for people overall.
That is exactly what I stand for.
- I'm not sure that
socialism is the answer.
Yugoslavia before World War II did okay,
but they didn't do all that great,
and they were taken over quite quickly.
What I'm thinking is capitalism,
although is not the best solution,
is one of the best solutions
for a democratic society.
- Think about socialism,
you think about wealth distribution.
And then money becomes
a very big role too,
because the ones that have less money
become envious of those
that have more money.
And then money, it becomes a God,
because you don't want anyone
else to have that money,
but yourself.
And if you, for example, look
at the Scandinavian countries,
they have a capitalistic market,
but they have a socialist
wealth distribution.
And that's why it works over there.
And I personally come from
Europe, so I have seen that.
- So you think that works?
- I personally don't think that works.
I think it takes a lot
of money from the rich,
and from the middle class.
- My name is Nathan, I'm 18 years old.
I would like to ask the other side,
if they believe America
is the greatest country
in the world.
If they disagree with that,
I want to know what country they believe
is better than America.
I do believe it's a blessing
and it's a privilege,
to live in a country that
gives you the liberty
and freedom, and to
express who you wanna be.
- [Narrator] The American dream is dead.
- I gotta say I disagree with
the phrase American dream,
and American dream for who?
The native Americans we slaughtered,
the enslaved people.
This romantic idea that
there's this dream,
is just basically
marketing for capitalism.
It's very well funded propaganda,
and has it inspired, good acts,
and good people to do good things?
Of course, of course.
Because ultimately, in a large sense,
humanity is good.
But this idea of the American dream,
I think the fantasy of it is
being torn apart a little bit.
And I think that's actually exciting,
because it opens up room
for something better,
something more inclusive to grow.
- I think the phrase is kind of corny,
but the idea that someone's
like building themselves up
in capitalism,
I feel like that I kind
of have done that a bit
with my business.
So I don't think it's dead.
- I do think the American
dream is dying though.
The American dream now,
is not the same as it was 30 years ago.
Have a family, buy a
home, have a great job,
but now it's very difficult to buy a home.
Income has not increased
compared to the price of a house.
I do think it's dying though,
but I don't think it's completely dead.
Because there's a lot of immigrants
who are still trying to come to America.
America does have the
highest immigrant population,
14% of our population are immigrants.
We have a lot of people
on our Southern border,
and I think they all
want to come to America.
- Yeah, I think the
American dream still exists,
and I can speak firsthand,
because my family came
from a third world country.
But so does the American nightmare.
The people suffering, not just here,
but also around the
world, due to policies,
due to exploitation, due to colonization,
due to a lot of issues that are
directly at hand to America.
So there's a lot of blood
on the United States hand.
And a lot of people don't
wanna leave their home country.
But the situations that
have been created there,
are forcing people to leave.
Like my mother would've
loved to stay in Mexico,
but unfortunately, due to poverty,
which had a lot to do with
NAFTA, and what happened in 1994,
directly caused
by the United States.
- Yeah.
- Issues that created this migration.
So is it a better opportunity here? Yes.
My people come here, and
we send our money back,
to our ancestors.
Would we just like to
stay where we're from?
Yeah, that would be a much better option.
- As an immigrant myself,
I definitely think that the
American dreams still exists.
We long for the opportunities
that people have here
in America, for the job
opportunities that people have,
the innovations that are available,
in this free market economy,
this capitalist country.
- So the American dream is
in the eye of the beholder.
If you're an immigrant, or if
you live here, it's different.
It's gonna be different.
- I don't like the idea
of the American dream,
but I am a person who's still
gonna always believe in hope.
If you work hard and you take
advantage of opportunities,
you can make a difference in your life.
I mean, you're an example
of it, I'm so amazed by you.
I think it's awesome, what
you're doing at such a young age.
I am very, very impressed with you three.
My hope for you is that
you stay open-minded,
and that you're always
willing to be learners,
and not just listeners.
- Yeah.
- [Narrator] All right, great.
(all clapping)
- Thank you for coming today.
- Yeah.
- Appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- Be a good lawyer someday Nathan.
- Thank you. (Nathan laughs)